now it's being seen as the great hope
for generating
clean power nuclear fusion today
scientists in france start assembling an
enormous international
nuclear fusion reactor known by the
acronym eta
french president emmanuel macron is
hosting a ceremony to mark the milestone
it's already taken 10 years in a global
scientific effort to get this far
and now the main construction of the
huge complex in southern france
will begin with components sent from all
over the world
the idea is to create energy not by
splitting atoms like nuclear power
stations do now
but by fusing them together
[Music]
for decades scientists have been trying
to tap into
the power that drives the sun nuclear
fusion
the hope is that it can be used to meet
tomorrow's energy demands
the basic science is that in conditions
like those found in the sun
such as very high temperatures hydrogen
atoms will fuse
create helium and release a lot of
energy
the hydrogen could be extracted from
seawater
making it a practically unlimited
resource
fusion is basically the the opposite of
conventional nuclear
so in nuclear power you're splitting a
heavy element and that releases
energy but you end up with the the
products afterwards which
can be quite hard to handle fusion is is
not a
a chain reaction so there's no
possibility for it to run away which is
what causes
meltdown
scientists at this startup in the uk are
working on nuclear fusion
one of the biggest hurdles they face is
how to get
more energy out of the process than they
have put in
researchers in southern france are also
working on fusion
the international project eater is
building a giant experimental reactor
it seeks to use heat to cause hydrogen
to fuse
the reactor design is what's called a
tokamak
a huge hollow donut filled with super
hot hydrogen plasma
that flows through it like a ring of
lightning held in place by powerful
magnets
it has proved to be a major technical
challenge
and it's still hard to predict how
fusion energy can be fed into the power
grid
many think it could take at least two
more decades
before this problem can be solved
we are now joined by hartmut zom one of
the german scientists involved in the
eta project professor tsom the tocomark
reactor in france
is a giant experiment involving
scientists from across the world
what is it hoping to achieve
so what it's hoping to achieve is the
proof of principle that we can get net
energy
from nuclear fusion on earth as was said
this is the
source of the energy of of the stars of
our sun for example so we're fusing
hydrogen nuclei we have to make these
very hot its gas which goes up to 100
million degrees
we have made this possible in our
experiments already but we always had to
put in more energy to heat up the gas
then the
energy which is released from nuclear
fusion eta will be the first experiment
that shows that we can get
a net gains or more energy from fusion
than we deposit in the plasma to heat it
now nuclear fusion has been called the
holy grail if you like of clean energy
is it really as safe and green as it's
cracked up to be
okay that of course depends who is going
to crack it up to be
so i think it's it's clear that it will
be sustainable
because the primary fuels are deuterium
which is a hydrogen isotope from
seawater and lithium
from which we generate the tritium the
other
hydrogen isotopes are lithium and
deuterium
are very widespread across the world and
they are enough
to sustain for hundreds and thousands of
years hundreds
thousands of years our energy demand so
it's clearly sustainable
it is clean in the sense that it does
not produce any co2
or any uh emission of gases which you do
not want in the atmosphere
it is also safe because it cannot have
this sort of
uncontrolled meltdown of
all the device also the energy contained
in it is not enough for this
it does however produce radioactive
wastes so the structural materials
around
of which the machine consists will be
activated
but different from fission these will
have a half-life time that after say a
hundred years
you could touch and reprocess them very
different from the millions of years we
are talking fission where you really
have to put things deep
underground and store it away for long
term so there is no long-term storage
envisaged for the radioactive stuff
which comes out of nuclear fusion
reactors
all this sounds fantastic and ideal
therefore
when can we expect to see our energy
needs powered by nuclear fusion
okay this this depends a bit on your
strategy so if you do this sequentially
like we do in the eu
we will have ether going into operation
projected in up to five years from now
and then showing the net energy gain
around 2035
we would then decide to build a
follow-up
real reactor which would also produce
net electricity to the net
which could do this by in the 2040s or
say 2050 and then it could be
deployed however if you are more hungry
for energy like the chinese for example
they are thinking about
building a demonstration reactor in
parallel to ether
so this could produce electricity by
2035 or 40 or so so 10 to 15 or 20 years
earlier and so the deployment could also
be
these 10 to 15 years earlier it depends
a bit on your strategy and how
much you want it hartmut zone from the
max planck institute thank you so much
sir
you're welcome